dude
uh friday night
i had one of the drunkest crowds i've
had in a minute it was oh yeah i saw
your uh it was sorry it's basically
there's like this group of women that
came in from like massachusetts
they like drove
like across state lines because it was
real close
and um
they were like celebrating a divorce
so i was about to go on stage and i
heard them coming in and they were
already drunk just like
chirping and like as they were making
their way to their table they're like
kind of already heckling
my guy's zyada's opening
and i'm like oh boy i'm [ __ ] in for
it then there's these two girls in front
of me they're nice but like as they
start drinking and like getting deeper
in the show
one of the
one of them is
not making the connection on my jokes
so then there's like this delay where
every time i tell a joke
this girl in front of me would explain
the joke to her friend as i'm trying to
move on to the next thing and then there
were people who just wanted to see the
show so i'm like doing this weird
balancing act where i'm like doing some
material
that i do crowd work and by the end of
it i literally cut half my material i'm
like all right i'm just gonna
just talk [ __ ] to the crowd now but it
went well
yeah yeah it went good you know by the
end of it the girls the women in the
back were like literally trying to fight
people they were like like during the
show and like
yeah like they were drunk and just going
at it like
someone told them that someone tried to
shush them
they did not have that they were like
[ __ ] you why did they tell me to be
quiet
i know right show dude
you're not supposed to be talking ever
at this thing yeah you're not the one
who talks that guy talks
[Music]
but you know what they're like i'm not
even i'm not even loud
yeah i'm not even [ __ ] loud
all right dude what do you think of
drake's album
um
honestly
don't say it don't say if you say never
mind right now
okay
honestly
i kind of liked it
did you
yeah everyone was hating everyone was
you know hating on like the spongebob
song
yeah which one
uh is it current
it's after text go green
okay
um
because it's the one with the bed
squeaking sample
okay
um
which first of all
there are some people being like dude
this bed squeaking sound are you [ __ ]
kidding me and i'm like have you heard
some cut like
that's one of the dopest songs ever yeah
uh so i didn't i didn't really take
issue with the sample like a lot of
other people were getting all butt hurt
about but it is like the classic like
yeah like that [ __ ] yeah that's a great
sound what are you talking about i don't
i don't know man and then um i did think
it was funny it's in like tons of r b
songs
i mean it's it's featured in a like it's
just a very
like
uh
familiar sound i feel like even
you know
so a couple things uh so yeah like i i i
didn't i didn't mind the album like um
i think it's interesting that everyone's
like drake needs to experiment he does
the same [ __ ] every time
so he tried something and then it's just
immediately like this is ass
go back to doing the other [ __ ]
so i think it just kind of underscores
when you're a big artist like that like
it's it's really hard to win unless
you're like uh
unless you're like harry styles i feel
you where you know everything you do
touches go it's like it's gold but
um
did you catch that like it didn't even
hit me i saw his tick tock pointing out
like the melody he uses on that bed
squeaking song is that it's basically
the same as that tick tock that's like
spongebob spongebob patrick patrick
squidward hold on what's the connection
with spongebob
because everyone is saying well everyone
weirdly was comparing that bed squeak to
um spongebob's boots i'll take
what did you say yeah yeah play the
squeaky boots yeah
now i'm an official fry cook
[Music]
ah great show isn't it yeah
classic man it got me smiling
about play the song now
like a jersey house song
yes like a jersey house song that's
that's what the sample is so
it's like the genre it's used most is
jersey house so you know what's really
interesting is
right before this dropped aj tracy did
you listen to him no
he's like a uk rapper he put out
like a jersey house type song as well
so
it just it makes me think like
you know because you know did drake's
team like get together and do some
research and they're like you know what
hasn't been like really broken into the
mainstream
in front of like this generation is like
jersey house so maybe we do that you
know what i mean like yeah
and uh
uh
so yeah yeah i
i didn't
i don't know how much of it i'll
re-listen to but
i don't know
it's fine yeah to me my biggest gripe
with it is that it sounded like he made
it in 20 minutes yeah there's no there's
like there's one vocal track
per song yeah and he repeats melodies
like non-stop it's crazy and and one
after another have to end lyrics too
yeah the writing is just like
non-existent yeah it's like he went in
and was like
it's almost like he was like oh i want
to make something completely different
in the next two weeks and like made that
a project for himself which is fine
whatever i mean it's not like it was
marketed as some like crazy
you know
piece of work that he spent a lot of
time on so maybe that was the case
but it just surprised me how simple and
how
repetitive it was and yeah and to me it
can like i like the vibe of some of it
but it some of it sounds like you could
be walking by
you know like a resort pool and it would
be playing out of like a speaker and a
plant
yeah i mean everyone you know had you
know said the same thing
the best way i saw this joke phrased was
a a girl posting text between her and
her boyfriend her boyfriend was like
it's cool but i feel like i'm trying on
jackets at zara
yeah
and everyone is like this is gonna go
crazy in the h m like
yeah it definitely is is very
super background music like it's like
i could see some dj
at 5 30 a.m yep in santorini yep
dropping one of these songs and all the
drugged out people the just the the
hangers on you know the last legs of
that party just like [ __ ] hell yeah
yeah
it's uh
it's it's just it's whatever like
i guess do what you want to do
but yeah
the cover art is sick though
yeah yeah definitely get enough of that
[ __ ] dude i want that on a shirt
yeah the aesthetic is pretty cool
i think um
uh maybe
he knew love island was coming back so
that's why he dropped it
this just gonna go crazy before the
commercials dude
you